welcome to the michaela peterson podcast
this is episode
75 and features three artistes
this is an episode on how artists think
the people who really pursue art
certainly have brains that work
differently than mine
i interviewed yulia fogra the
illustrator behind my dad's newest books
illustrations
here's an example of her work
i interviewed cesar santos an absolutely
incredible portrait artist
who has art like this
and i interviewed my mom who's very
talented at sculpture and charcoal
drawing
amongst many other things what i found
most interesting about all these
conversations
is the similarities between these people
about how they think
purely visually not in words if you
would i'd like to see what you guys
think about this and how you think
if you could write whether you think in
words or pictures or both in the
comments that might be cool to scroll
through
if you like this content please hit
subscribe this episode is brought to you
by true local
i just interviewed the ceo who's an
absolute powerhouse of a human
mark that episode should be great it's
coming
anyway true locals where i get most of
my meet in canada they connect you with
local
farmers and connect you with some of the
best meat that you can find
a hundred percent grass-fed and
grass-finished beef pasture-raised or
rwa chicken
rwa means raised without antibiotics for
those who don't know
lamb bison and over a hundred different
cuts of meat that you can't
generally find at your grocery store
some areas have wild boar
too like i said you get connected with
local butchers
you build your own personalized box that
will give you enough meat for the month
with only the products you want and it
shows up at your door
and with code mp you get free steaks in
your order
at trulocal.ca they make getting
healthier
very easy i hope you enjoy this episode
[Music]
so
[Music]
mom welcome back to my podcast hi
michaela
good to see you good to see you too
i'm more tan than you
yep that's unusual actually isn't it
yeah it is it is very unusual well you
never used to talk
about it so remember when you were young
you didn't tan so now you tan because
you're healthy
so that's yeah i didn't tan i stayed
green all the time it was shocking
i didn't even really burn i just didn't
change color yeah
anyway you look healthy yeah now look at
me i'm giving julian a run for his money
anyway i wanted to ask you a little bit
about art
okay because you are an artiste
all right i'm ready
do you think in pictures or words
pictures
do you only think in pictures i do not
think in words
well god speaks to me in words
take that
i will take that somehow i don't know
what to do with that
i had two other people on this podcast a
portrait artist
and uh the illustrator for dad's books
oh yeah and both of them told me that
they
thought in pictures yeah i think in
pictures
for sure when i meditate sometimes i get
amazing pictures
so meditation is very fun for me because
if they want you to think
in colors and so i i can i can find the
colors you know
with my eyes shut okay i i can do that
but is there a voice that'll accompanies
it
no not usually unless i'm praying to
understand something
oh that's fascinating okay so when i
think i i think in pictures like very
visually
but there's always a voice and so that's
what i assume people
well i have voices but they're usually
not very smart voices
they're they're like you know
manipulative and uh resentful and angry
and oh like they're the they're the
voices of
of uh past pain those voices that come
up
uh if i'm present
no there's no voices except for the ones
that i'm
saying that's actually
probably a good point because if i have
moments of like clarity after i'm
exercising or if i'm feeling
really good and i'm not stressed and i'm
not thinking about work
and that rarely happens but if i'm doing
really good then
i can walk down the street and just kind
of be
present so maybe that maybe that's part
of what stops
all the voices being in the present
stops all the voices
yep perhaps okay well we got away from
thinking in words
i wonder what people mean by thinking in
words then that they visualize words
or that they don't visualize or do they
hear they hear the words i guess
or it's just the voice okay maybe people
in the comments will let me know i don't
know
at the beginning of this conversation i
thought i knew and now i don't
the voices being the past traumas and
everything else if that's true okay
anyway when did you know um you
wanted to pursue art
well i always
really liked coloring drawing
making marks on paper looking
at nature so when i was a little kid i
was very
i colored all the time and my
grandmother sometimes taught me some art
techniques and i really liked
doing that i can remember that very well
because my grandma
grandmother was an artist on my mom's
side and i had an aunt
on my dad's side who's an artist too so
i had some artists in my family which
was
fortunate at least i had that but other
than that i had no
um there was no art classes in my high
school in
rural alberta you know and there was no
art
center that kids could go to and do
stuff so we never
i i didn't do any pottery i didn't
do any i did a little bit of photography
with a really primitive camera and i
liked that a lot
so i was always visual you know i was
always looking for
um in grade six i drew
a i put classical music
to a kid's book and i drew all of the
pictures that would go along with it so
i was always doing that kind of thing
but in terms of an artist um
i had already done a lot of drawing um
i was probably 30 and we were in
boston george had just got a job at
harvard
and someone from the friends of harvard
called me and asked me told me there was
going to be an art exhibit
that was going to be hosted by the
friends of of harvard which would be all
the
you know spouses of professors and she
asked me if i was an artist
and i turned around and looked around
the bedroom and there was no one there
and i said
yes i'm an artist
[Laughter]
but i've never really said that before
that
so i was 30. huh i remember when i was
little
um you taught me how to draw a face
which i want to get into a little bit um
afterwards but i was i was good enough
at drawing faces when i was in
kindergarten that i taught the
kindergarten teacher how to draw
faces and you taught me how to draw
faces
so how did you learn how to draw people
because you're really good at drawing
people
yeah i think that just came naturally to
me um
i can remember when i was
20 i was probably 20 i lived in edmonton
i think for a year when i was about 20
or 19 or 20
18 19 20. and an old guy came to sharpen
our knives
you know how guys come around the
neighborhood sharpening knives
but he came in the house and was sitting
in the living room
and i got out a piece of paper and some
watercolors
and i drew him and painted him and i'd
never done that before but that was
right when i started
modeling for artists so i
when i went to edmonton i needed money
to go to university and they were hiring
artists
or hiring models for artists in the
art department so i applied and got the
job and then i would watch the artists
in the
classes okay so that was the beginning
of my
education because i'd watch what they
did
and then i started buying art paper
and pastels i think i started with
oil pastels which i never use anymore i
always use chalk pastels
but you know because oil pastels they're
brilliantly colored but they are not
forgiving at all whereas chalk pastels
are you can layer them really nicely i
guess you can with oil too but
is i never really used much oil paint
either although
i might have it was just that oil paint
it was it was kind of toxic because you
had to use
paint thinner to clean it and it's
really smelly and
so i wasn't really wanting to do that
especially when i had little kids around
but i'm still not all that interested in
it because it's smelly
and toxic and toxic no thanks to that
well you can get oil paints now that you
are you can
wash with water so i might try them
again
do you have suggestions for people
who don't know how to draw on how to
start
well i drew i read a book called drawing
on the right side of the brain i think
that's what it's called
it's a really good book drawing on the
right side of the brain
and it gives you exercises one of the
exercises i remember was
there was a picture of a a drawing a
line drawing of a man
and it was turned upside down and you
were supposed to draw it upside down
i might have had you guys do that i'm
not sure
and that way you're looking at the lines
and the angles and you're not looking at
something as a face
and so then you can turn it right back
up the other thing i've been doing
recently
and i've been doing this a long time but
still you could do this to begin
is say you have a a picture you're
copying
from another picture and you've done
quite a bit of it
if you take a picture of that with your
camera
and then look at the picture that you're
that you're drawing you can see where
you've made mistakes way easier than you
can if you just look at
what you've drawn so both those things
turning things upside down and i used to
do when i used to draw portraits
i would turn the portraits upside down
and stand back from them and draw
and then turn them back up again because
you get so that you're
you know the left side of your brain is
too
active and it's keeps defining what
you're doing by
what it is that you're drawing and all
you're supposed to be looking at is the
angles
um i did a i did a drawing recently that
you saw that i posted on instagram
and i really like doing that because it
was of a robot
and it was of pieces of wood
it's all angles so there's not a lot of
the only thing that was tricky was the
eyes because
the eyes they have to look like eyes
even though they were
robot eyes and you so you had to get
them
so precise for them to give you the
feeling of eyes you have to
you know you have to have you have to
almost
touch it or you know like shape it if it
was clay it's like you really want to
have
the essence of an eye to make it look
like it's looking
at you or at whatever it's looking
at i think one of the good things
i think one of the things that was
really helpful that you taught me when i
was learning how to draw
was don't look at what you're looking at
for what it is like if you're trying to
draw a nose
don't draw a nose like what you think a
nose looks like
look at the shapes and if you just look
at the shape
and then put the shape on a piece of
paper
it'll end up being a nose for example
you
know
people starting have trouble with noses
on faces for some reason i think it's
because they're
maybe it's because noses look really
different they're trying to figure out
what a nose looks like well noses are
pretty strange looking
right and to draw something that is as
strange looking as a nose is
you have to be pretty uh objective
because if you're trying to make it look
like a nose
well they're just such strange things
you pretty much have to draw the angles
of it to get it to look like a nose
i i took a course recently i really
liked it um
it was we were drawing faces but we were
also drawing
hands and feet and bodies and i really
liked the teacher who was teaching me
but he would just in order to draw a
person
circle for the head um
uh quadrangle for the
rib cage bigger at the top and smaller
at the bottom
you know like like where are me
like this yeah
so and then a circle for the red a
circle for the hips
and then uh you so you just do
shapes for every part of you really
basic shapes
you do the spine you kind of get an idea
of which way the spine goes and then you
put these shapes
on the spine and then you start to flesh
it out so it's almost like a skeleton
but it isn't but it's a skeleton in
terms of
a drawing so whatever you want to draw
whenever you want to draw someone you
make a skeleton of it first
kind of you make a uh an armature for it
in the beginning and then you put the
features and everything on same with if
you're drawing a face
you do the same thing you know you
decide oh yeah you draw
an oval and then you draw a line halfway
down that's where the eyes are going to
be is halfway down
and that's so hard to believe because
it's really hard to believe that this is
half your face
and this is the other half but if you
look at it right if i go like that and
then i move down it's half your face
and it just it's unbelievable that it's
half your face
because all of this is smushed into half
your face
yeah the rest of it is like yeah
and that's why little kids too when they
first start to draw they'll put their
eyes
like people's eyes way up here
notice that do you have things to show
so this is the professor that i studied
with
we did an exercise a couple exercises
yeah that that works so this oh yeah
there was a woman when is that from
that's from about a month ago okay
that's really hard we got it you can
take that down okay
this one this one that one
um was it was a picture of
that's pretty good i haven't seen that
it was one man
in one pose and then another figure
superimposed on top in another color and
another person
superimposed on top of that one i like
that one that one
turned out really good and then the
other one i wanted to show you was this
one that i posted online
that i just did yeah and that one
is from 1914.
surrealist a greek yeah that one's
really cool
and it was really fun to draw and i
think it was all angles but you see his
eyes
those black eyes those were hard to get
they were very tricky yeah
very subtle curves on them and and i
like that
i really like doing that kind of thing
and it's all measurement and i don't
measure with a
ruler but you're always having to
you know this is this big and this is
this big and this is that far down from
there and this is this far from here and
so
you're just you know and and you have to
see the whole thing at once
and then you can look at it but what
what i did was i covered the whole page
with a grid
so all of this oh that's another trick
that's another trick people should know
yeah trick so i covered the whole piece
of paper
with a 4b or 5b pencil in
and you do it do little squares
in different angles all over and then
rub it with a kleenex
so it gives you a background that's not
white and then take an eraser
just a plain white eraser you can cut
the end off so it's nice and white
and then when you're looking at what
you're doing you can look at the light
parts of it
and you can draw you can erase so it's
very subtle
very subtle marks on there and that's
really fun
and then you can bring your pencil in
and start
putting in the darks but i've used that
grid i drew a picture of van gogh's
house when he had to go home and live
when he was probably
i don't know how old he was maybe 20 and
depressed
and not happy and his father i guess was
not very kind to him
and he had to go home and live and do it
and he lived in the
in the house i think but he had this
little art studio beside and it was just
a little
garage you know and he drew this
drawing out of uh with with graphite
it's very dark i drew that but it was
kind of a depressing
thing to draw that sounds really
depressing well i knew what happened to
him
and yeah it's just it was beautifully
done but it was
sad but taking a course of
um things you know looking at
pictures that are in the museum and
drawing them because that's super good
practice
because you're drawing from you know the
best
yeah i like that eraser trick so you put
a
grid on the paper and you you draw
what's light and then you're not even
making any mistakes
oh you can just you can just draw right
you can x over it again you can put
and then rub it again and it's gone and
then you can start over
so it's very gentle yeah if you're
worried about making mistakes
and you do yeah you know like this
picture that i did here
i moved all this stuff around lots of
times
but but you wouldn't know that now
do you think people who end up
expressing themselves
with visual art do you think they're
doing that because they've
gone through something hard like
something difficult and that's a way to
express like do you think that's kind of
a
underlying theme with artists yes i do
i do think that i think that a lot of
people are struggling
and they show it you know people do that
with music
right they use they write songs
you know all cowboys all cowboys are
write rough songs
but um there's more
there's more to it than that though like
my idea of
wanting to put something down on paper
and spending time doing something
visual is uh it's not
i don't even have anything in mind i
just want to do it
i just want to spend my time doing that
being
engaged in that and this is very
interesting so
uh you know that i set up a place in my
basement that's a good
art place with really nice lighting and
uh
i cut out a wall my old bedroom no in
the middle
in the middle you know where you guys
used to have the tv
i cut out the wall there there's so
there's no wall there now it's an open
space
to the stairs and the door and the door
has a light and the light from upstairs
comes down because the stairs
are just they're not uh solid
so there's there's lots of light and i
have really good lighting up above
and i have a very nice desk and so
that's my place to do art and i had
started
even this art piece but i just showed
you i'd started that
and i wanted to work on it more but i
would walk by it and in my head there's
a there's a word
no i'd walk by it and when i went to sit
down to do it
i would hear no and i would walk by it
and i couldn't get myself to sit down
and do art and i know lots of people
have these problems
of it's not exactly it's procrastination
i guess but it's not exactly
procrastination it's an
inability to do what you want to do
you know you have something in you that
is special and
it's exciting and makes you
feel good and you won't let yourself do
it
and um i because it's a waste of time or
something oh yeah i told jordan i said
you know i'm saying no to myself
and he said why are you saying no and i
said well my artistic ability
wasn't valued in my
family my family my mom grew up
poor and my mom and dad
made a good life and they did it because
they were
they were conservative and they were
business people
you know they didn't go to university
either of them and they still made lots
of money they were business people and
they expected us
to be business people or to be nurses or
doctors or
physiotherapists or lawyers or you know
something
official and when i wanted to do art
they would like what they liked sports
you know if i wanted to do sports oh
yeah they were right behind that sports
was a good idea
but art wasted time it's like someone
saying they want to go to the olympics
and you know that's kind of a waste of
time if you're not
a one in a thousand person but you can
be an
artist you can enjoy art no matter who
you are
and i think that everybody has an
ability to do
something i'm not saying everybody's
creative but i think
if you have a feeling like you'd want to
do something
there is probably something that you
would enjoy doing you just haven't
discovered it maybe you want to make
quilts i had a friend who
i used to draw in her house and she
would always tell me
that she wasn't artistic and i would say
oh that's not true and she'd say no i'm
not artistic
i'd say oh you just haven't found your
medium she ended up
designing and making lots of quilts and
so
that's artistic as far as i'm concerned
it's the craft
side of art it's not the fine art side
it's the craft side but that's
we all have beautiful quilts in our
houses and we love them
so it's all good crafts are fun
like little kids love that and then we
just lose it
like beating or gluing things
making candles i loved making candles
did i ever did
we ever use a milk jug and put ice in it
and a wick and pour
wax in and let the oh i used to do that
when i was a kid
that's a really fun thing so you put ice
cubes in a
milk container or something that's
cardboard a cardboard container
and then you put a wick in there and you
pour wax in
and you let it cool you let the wax cool
and when you peel off the
cardboard the ice melts and it's just a
really holy
candle it's very cool
i can do that with scarlet yeah yeah
that that's really fun
making candles is really fun it's really
dangerous for kids though because it's
really hot so right oh
okay maybe not then she can watch but
yeah it's really really really
hot and sticky wax sticks to people and
it's disaster if it gets on anybody
okay do you have any anything else there
to show us or those are your two reasons
don't no i i have some in my condo but
i'm not in my condo
no i i took some i used to put them up i
put them up in my room
but they're not here in here but i don't
think there's anything here
no i think this is all current stuff
and i don't throw anything out i was
taught never to throw anything away
so i don't so i have a whole
cupboard full of art and i've given away
quite a bit of art i've only i don't
even know if i've sold anything
i might have but i can't remember if i
sold it or gave it away
and it doesn't really matter to me
yeah just do it well i want to do it
together this episode
i wanted to put together this episode
because people are so
at least in canada not here but
people are struggling so much because of
the lockdowns well i wanted to finish
what i was saying because i started
saying that i said no to myself right i
said no to myself
jordan i'm saying no to myself i think
it's because
art i don't value art or something
inside me doesn't value art my history
my understanding is that art isn't worth
it but
but it is to me and so then
we made a deal that when george left for
a walk he'd say are you going to go do
something important and i would say yes
and then i would go and do some art and
that isn't exactly what's happened but i
have made
time for art and this this week i worked
um
probably nine hours on art this wow
yeah and that's way better that's before
i was having a hard time
even sitting down to do it and so
recognizing what's stopping you
and giving and and sharing it with
someone because you need
it's really hard to change on your own
uh i told jordan i needed i just needed
a little bit of
um incentive a little bit of a pat on
the back
that that's all i needed was just
somebody noticing if i was
doing it or not and i i don't want him
to tell me what to do that makes me
that puts my back up if if he says ask
me what i'm going to do
i don't really want to tell him because
it's what i'm doing
but i really appreciate that he asks me
about it
and also asks me if i did anything that
day
i like that it's good and so if you
say you want to do something
it really does sound like me don't ask
me like i don't want
help i just want acknowledgement
but acknowledgement really is useful
and and i think really really helpful at
least it was for me
and so i hope that that might help some
people
if you're feeling stuck if you should
tell someone you're stuck
and try to figure out what it is what
what what
emotion you're feeling or if there's
anything
that comes to you like a word came to me
it was no
and uh if you can talk about that and
make a plan on how to
get by that and overcome that it's
it's really worth it maybe
reach out to a friend even and say hey
i'm
i want to do art and i'm worried do you
think i could just
get some acknowledgement over here and
if you're your friend
they'll probably give it to you yeah do
it you should do it maybe that's all you
need
yeah yep do it and did you do it
you should do it do it and did you do it
did you do it
yeah yeah okay that's good i like that
let's see what you did okay i'll meet
you
yeah how to go if you want to tell me
yeah
okay well thank you very much for
popping in nice to see you
nice to see you too thank you very much
that was fun
thanks for coming on my pleasure
[Music]
yulia welcome to my podcast thank you
okay how long have we known each other
we were just talking about this
more than a year okay so
i'm gonna get in february and that's the
end of march
oh jesus well things are definitely
better now than they were last february
yeah yeah
yulia is the person that has illustrated
dad's newest book with absolutely
absurd illustrations they're
fantastic they're like masterpieces
but we connected over social media i
don't know how i
found you i think maybe you know what
somebody told me about you
and then i think that's how we connected
i think i found you on twitter or
something i don't know what happened
but um i looked at your stuff and it was
like somebody texted you
on twitter about me someone dm'd me on
twitter about you and i looked at your
artwork and i was like this is
absurd like i said um so so that's my
intro
but could you give i mean people know
you because you were on dad's podcast
but for those who
of them i'll link that below too whoever
hasn't watched dad's podcast can you
give a brief background of yourself
myself it's a long story because i'm old
brief so i was born in latvia in the
soviet era
under the soviet uh under the russian
occupation so
you can sell safely that i lived in
russia although i didn't
the only difference from russia was the
architecture
the town the old town was built by
germans
it was beautiful but it was very far
away from me as a kid and i couldn't
just
go by car or any public transportation
so i was just stuck in my neighborhood
which was
a russian middle class
as i said domino like those endless
rolls of nine story buildings
so it was awful i was trying to escape
this
place although i didn't know it's
possible
and when the soviet collapsed in 1992
my dad finally said he we we were
traveling
me and my mom were in a vacation in
georgia and when it happened we were in
georgia and we couldn't come back from
there
all the traveling was stopped yeah and
um
the army came into the city and we
didn't think we'll come back and he
didn't think
he'll meet us because all the
connections were
cut we couldn't call or anything and he
thought he'll never meet us again
and when we finally arrived
he started believing and due to
so their family history
of living when something like this
happens because i'm jewish
uh we've lost most of our family to the
holocaust
so there was stories in my family
that you have to live on time otherwise
and we left we left to israel
for nine years that's brief
and nine years into living in israel
i was just following my husband to new
york who said i'm leaving this place
again so
um i said i'll never go to america i've
been watching movies hollywood movies
that's all we've been watching and
saying no that's not going to happen
and he said you have to come and see
this place he convinced me i came and
then stayed
forever that's why i'm here
everything is completely coincidental
everything is completely
not planned
geez that is a stressful way to live um
yeah yeah yeah
okay that was intense i would recommend
to anybody listening to check out the
podcast dad
um did with yulia because that's
much longer than this one um and you'll
get like you'll hear all about our story
and it's a really good podcast um so
assuming people have watched that
i wanted to ask a couple of art
questions because i wanted to make this
an intro to art
um podcast and i'm having
i have a couple of other artists on it
that
all have pretty interesting stories um
so i guess i'll start off
do you think when did you know you were
as artistic as you are have you always
been an artist
i still don't know i'm artistic you are
definitely artistic
i don't know that i always thought of
myself as a fraud
because i couldn't imposter syndrome
well it's more than that uh artists were
people who
paint from imagination prior to
photography
they were completely ah yeah it was
imagined
imaginative and i couldn't draw a dog if
you ask me
a four-legged dog i could draw
a square maybe out of my i had no
imagination so i was considering myself
a fraud
i was just a side project i never dug
into it
and when people call me an artist i
cringe inside
i don't like to be called it because i
know i'm not
i disagree i think you could let
yourself off the hook there
there are many different types of art
the the last person i interviewed was a
portrait artist
and he paints from memory
or he'll oh it's insane
but the type of the type of art you do
and i'd like you to describe it a little
bit
it it has the same it gives me the same
emotional reaction
um as that and i think that's what
makes art like people can't just make
the type of art you're doing
so could you uh give a brief description
about
like what type of art you make it is art
so um okay so i knew i'm not an artist
i didn't like to be an artist so i found
a back door
i found another way to entrance the same
thing
without my abilities to draw from
imagination
or fine art
which looks like a lot of like fine art
i was looking for a way that i can just
trespass and do that somehow and i found
i could
with jordan not prior to that
so when i saw jordan what yes yes
there must have been something you
didn't just oh my god did you just
convince me
you made the fool i made the phone you
made that video we had a contest
oh mike are you kidding me no how do i
not know this
well you nailed it so i was holding my
head like this because
i really needed to do this somehow i
just
needed to do this i wasn't even thinking
of winning
just what i need to do this somehow and
i knew i can't make a lot
dry no what was the description line
drawing
it's a very narrow description and i
couldn't do that
i'm not an illustrator or a painter or
any of those things
so my husband told me you just have to
go and do your thing
my thing i don't have my thing and i
told jordan about it
i had the teacups um
what do you call this the square the
square shaped
you have to help me with this a hot cup
a hot cup of tea you would not coaster
yeah coasters sorry coasters and
they had a fine art german drawings
paintings reproductions and i looked at
them and i said this is beautiful
i wish i could do that that would fit
the the theme of jordan's book that
would
it's black and white it's very close to
his first book illustrations
i have to do it somehow i went
downstairs
breaking my head and i've started this
thing that i call now photo montage
so what i did is i started make a list
of
keynotes what do i need for this
at minimum i needed a guy that looked
self-sufficient happy and arrogant
i thought he needs to be arrogant
otherwise he would not look uh
he would never fall off the cliff unless
he's
aware of what's going on he was just so
self-absorbed
and i needed a mountain i needed a
guy i needed a dog
i don't remember exactly the key words i
had like ten
and then i started to collect pieces of
visual uh
either photography or fine art doesn't
matter i was searching the web i've just
started to collect
those visual pieces of information
for hours then i looked at them
and i thought okay this one definitely
this sky definitely looks fit
this guy definitely if it worked if if i
change his posture i change his hat i
change
this and that it's all happening in my
head simultaneously
it's a mess and then i've started to
attach this
okay and the the scene i i'm
i'm liking what i'm seeing the scene is
very beautiful it's not something you
would see in real life
because it's not a real photo it's
constructed of different ideas
then i need to integrate them flawlessly
into each other
that's a that's a very hard task
and then i used my drawing abilities
whatever i did
was when i was a child but digitally
i started to paint over it to to cover
up some
flaws
that was a mess i was just trying really
hard to get this picture
i don't remember how i did it even but i
liked what i saw
that's what i sent
wow okay i think that mess in your head
that's probably what makes you an artist
i don't know if you can have one without
the other you're right
like i don't know if you can connect
ideas like that or
or think that's what's missing like i
don't know if you can think like that i
thought analytical thought it's nothing
to do with thinking
i was just turning my head off
completely
i was just not not there that's why it
was messy i was not thinking straight
i was trying to accomplish something
that's part of my psyche as well i'm
like that in life it's
probably a leo trait because i need to
get where i need to get
no matter what i'll crawl i'll die doing
this but i'll do it
somehow you know that i know that
i know that that's missing
cool okay do you have do you have
have advice for other people who want to
pursue something artistic
but don't have absolutely no way to
start and also don't consider themselves
artists
do your thing do your thing
and try not to think while you're doing
it because
your fears are really on the way that's
the only thing that's on the way your
fears and insecurities
so what helps me i would put music and
i'll work to music and music
takes my analytical thought away i'm
very emotional and takes me into the
different
yeah head sphere and try that
see what happens
that that's fantastic when um when i was
when i write when i when i'm not feeling
well
and i write um or i'm studying something
really hard it's not
it's not exactly the same but i used to
turn on
really loud beethoven because it didn't
have any words
so i didn't get distracted by the words
but it would block
out something like the it'd block out
the i don't know
insanity the like the mind racing
yeah kind of because it was so loud and
then i could focus on what i was doing
what do you listen to it depends on the
project i'm trying to fit
the music to the project when i did
jordan stuff that was classical music
for sure
there was a lot of shopping
depends on the project depends on um
flair
cool of course you're listening to 80s
mine was always beethoven really loud
beethoven
or or music that would go really quiet
and then suddenly really loud and then
really quiet
classical music like that with strings
interesting
or piano if i was feeling emotional
yep just try to use all of your skills
so i told you that i'm feeling very
cringed when people say i'm an artist
because i'm not and
i think it's a trap as soon as you start
to
consider yourself as an artist i think
you're trapped
in a confined space i'm me
when i'm doing something artistic i'm
just being me i'm not trying to
put limits and i can
then i can draw from anything i want all
the influences
from film uh structures
i would always watch movies or listen to
music and i would
see structures because i'm very visual i
don't think structures i i
see them and then i'm trying to recreate
them visually in my work
and that gives me the liberty of
absolutely
drawing from any direction because i'm
not an artist i'm just me
that's kind of kind of how i feel about
podcasting
kind of we're just like oh no i i don't
know what i'm doing
yeah you're not a podcaster i'm just
kidding
yeah yeah oh yeah okay i'm gonna ask
for i'm gonna ask for a little bit more
advice because that that was really
brave then
sending in an illustration but it was
like you nailed it
um you're you're pretty good at
it it might be incredibly nerve-wracking
from your point of view but from my
point of view you're pretty good at
asking for things
um which is a skill that i think north
americans are lacking
um so what what would you say to and i
think artistic types
a lot are are somewhat introverted maybe
that's wrong but
um what would you say to people who are
more yeah what would you say more in
their head or something
but what would you say to more
introverted people for trying to make
these connections in order to make this
into a business
is there a mindset or do you have advice
there like how do you
not at all because i'm just starting out
i'm still it doesn't fit my head still
whatever happened to me in the last year
it's not it's not here yet
it's somewhere there outside of me
but yeah that right but what it did to
me i'm starting my new book
i'm becoming very brave
that's what it did to me the experience
also i think what happened
which is very ironic when you get 100 or
hundreds of illustrations right
which you did for the full and they all
drawn
in line art right and then suddenly
something that's
outstanding which was i was not
following the rules exactly there were
lines
but it was not created in fine line
right fine
line i think that's one of the reason
that it was
outstanding what do you think
not following the rules exactly
ah i don't know it looked like a piece
of
like fine art it looked like a piece of
fine art
but you could also see it was
photography like it's just this weird
mesh
of things that i haven't seen before
yeah wow it's crazy you said you're
you mentioned a book yes okay
get into that what's happening
i'm making my own uh picture book
look that's a fantastic idea idea yes
and it's not my idea it's always my
husband's idea he's
he's like that's encouraging yeah
because i'm
i'm not an artist what are you talking
about book
me so now i'm working on my
family history with my cousin with my
aunt
with a writer there's gonna be the
history of my family
starting from pre-war war after war
and spreading to to today
there's going to be four or five of my
poems attached to
artworks and the rest of it is going to
be huge it's going to be a big book
something that's nice to hold and look
at
that's my idea so far that is
so cool we should we that is a fantastic
idea i think
wow writing your family so you know i've
been writing my book for like
since i was 17. yeah i've been working
on a well it was how i
kept saying like since i was in grade
one
whenever i got too angry or too
emotional i'd write in my journal and it
would kind of release some emotions
so i kept journals since grade one and
then when i was 17
and i had my hip and ankle replaced i
was like this is
so absurd that i have to write it out on
paper because i
don't understand and dad always taught
me to write out
what's been traumatizing you um so that
you can understand it and get over it
but um so so i've just continued writing
it forever
like oh that year was crazy better write
down that year was crazy better write it
down
but it's hard emotionally every year was
crazy am i right
like every yeah and it just got i was
like this was totally [ __ ] up and then
it just got worse and i was like
are you serious so i'm i'm not like 2018
i haven't written anything after that
but it's like
everything i write hurts it's hard
so i i i could i don't know
how like are you working on any of the
written part
even the illustrations though that's got
to be that's got to be hard
i think it's my way of expressing myself
usually
i know it's a
blah way of way of describing
i'm not writing because i'm not thinking
on words
you think in pictures that's not my mom
thinks in pic my mom thinks in pictures
like some people think in pictures it's
not blah or anything
especially not the illustrations you're
doing like they would fill you with the
same emotion reading something
emotional would fill you with that's got
to be hard i think it's my way of
expressing myself usually
i know it's a
blah way of way of
i'm not writing because i'm not thinking
on words
you think in pictures that's not my mom
thinks in pic my mom thinks in pictures
like some people think in pictures it's
not blah or anything
especially not the illustrations you're
doing like they would fill you with the
same emotion reading something
emotional would fill you with so you can
think about it that way
it's still all in there
it's not very logical i need to start
thinking in words
i never wrote my diary is uh
my cd collection or my vinyl connect
collection
that's my diary when i listen to this
all those memories and all those
emotions
are all there i can come back 20 years
back
yeah oh that's okay that's funny i um
so i get pictures and words my dad does
mostly words and my mom
thinks in pictures um but i have spotify
collections from
from each year and i i can listen to
them and be like
hoof that's what happened yeah but you
have vinyl so that's just like the
cooler version
mine's spotify though so it's portable
i can't lose my collection
of artists you look up to steve jobs
ah sneaky that was good why
no no i thought about it for a very long
time uh why
inspired by barack obama i do not
inspired by
visuals i told that to jordan i'm
inspired by music
film anything but visuals so it's steve
jobs
and after he was gone
it was a hole that was not replaced
until i met jordan
that's interesting so what was it about
steve jobs
hmm i was obsessed with the guy
he he was such a fine artist without
being an artist
he was orchestrating the biggest minds
the best people there are in the
industry he was not
uh he said once to steve wozniak i think
yeah steve wozniak he said
imagine this is an orchestra and you're
the best violin player
you're sitting here in front of me and
you're the best at what you do
and this guy is the best at what they do
and steve said
he said what is it about you
that everybody loves why is it you
you're not doing anything he said i'm
orchestrated
he's seen the whole picture he's very
much like female mind because men are
very
men are amazing at
narrowing their mind at the task right
and they
they they know exactly what they do and
we are just lost in that this is boring
to us
we more like seeing the whole picture
right that's how i see it and yeah steep
was
an exception i think because he saw the
whole picture
the whole world he saw in his head was a
and
jordan i also noticed that was profound
when jordan speaks in his lectures
it's like he built a map the size of the
city
he drew it he painted it he's an artist
jordan in my eyes
he painted a huge size map and then
he's just um scrolling it
okay i'm looking for this spot he got
there
then he's zooming in he's zooming in
zooming in and then he gets excited by
what he sees
he getting like a kid excited but what
he sees
the painting that he drew in the first
place
he's an amazing artist mind
irreplaceable that is that that is
probably the most accurate description
of my dad's lecturing style i've
ever heard that was cool
yeah and he's like okay and this piece
connected with that piece i remember it
was somewhere there let me remember
he scrolls he finds it aha yeah there is
a connection and he's
getting all excited about this
connection then he makes a pretzel
like this absolute pretzel form he comes
back to the beginning oh yeah no it's
perfect i get i used to get anxious in
lectures
because he'd he'd start somewhere and
he'd talk for like 45 minutes and the
lecture would be ending
and i'd be like you didn't bring it back
you didn't bring it back you didn't loop
it back to the beginning how are you
going to get it back to the beginning
and then he just go like zap right back
to the beginning of like
what yeah and he knew it
in his mind he knew he's going to find a
way it's just the matter of time
how long is going to take yeah
so to me it's steve jobs and jordan
peterson
damn do you ever get stuck for ideas for
art
always i'm stuck for ideas when i'm
starting something i don't have ideas
so what i do is um
i need to describe this person i need to
depict this person
i'm looking for every single visual i
can find
whatever catches my eye not every single
whatever catches my eye
i'm bringing it into a page and i'm
looking what can i make out of it
i have no ideas and no
[Music]
risk consumption i have
just nothing in my head i'm thinking
what can i do out of this
particular this starting to play with it
and then
probably a third through the process i'm
starting to get ideas
from the outside so for any for anybody
listening
julia creates these these pieces are
insanely complicated
you create them so fast it's
it boggles the mind
are you just in flow state like are you
just focused and
like you said not thinking just like
just a feeling
well three hours of flow state like a
lot of people can only get into that for
15 minutes
it's hard it's hard to get into actually
that's something we could talk about a
little bit and
and then i'll let you go but this flow
state
people spend you know a lot of time
trying to figure out how to get into it
and for some people that's writing
getting into it like when i'm writing my
book um
i write 3 000 words an hour which is
i think a lot from what i've read yeah
it just
pours out um and i stop because if i
if i write too much like if i go to 8
000 words
then i i don't write for like a week
like i can't handle it
right um so i've noticed i have to limit
myself
fairly limited but um people try really
hard to get into this flow state
so are there are there tricks you use or
is this something that
you just comes out to do with writings
with analytical thinking
15 minutes yeah makes sense i'm not
thinking
so three four hours is not a big deal
although i'm
i'm i'm flat in bed afterwards
for one day but that is so exciting the
next day i have to come back and try
again
and it's getting better and better and
better
every new thing i create gets better i
think
well i would say if you think it gets
better it probably does
because you're underestimating yourself
at the moment yeah and i
after the book i thought i'm done this
is all i have to say
this is all i can there is nothing more
i want to say for sure
just now i'm starting to feel there's
way more
i don't know how more but way more
i'm just starting to open up well 43
years
must do that to you
if you don't have anything to say 43
something's off
okay julia i'll i'll post your social
media links below because your social
media is really cool
um you put a whole bunch of your art up
and it it's a cool account to follow so
i'll post it below and in show notes but
where can people follow you online
i mostly live my life on instagram
not on twitter not on facebook instagram
yeah
instagram and what's your instagram
handle okay it's at
juliet dot okay so that's juliet just
spelled
normally dot f-o-g-r-a
for anyone listening and you can see her
art you can see the illustrations she
did for dad's books
and yeah thank you very much for coming
on it's so nice to finally meet you i
can't believe we've been
we've been emailing back and what's
happening back so much especially over
the summer
um in the last year it's been a wild
ride
so thank you very much for your help
[Music]
cesar santos welcome to my podcast thank
you so much michaela
i'm grateful that someone wants to talk
about such a
you know a theme that most people don't
talk about
so that's great can we well i think
people
underestimate the value of art so
we've been detached from it you know
we've been forced out of it
but we have an insight well and a lot of
people don't know how to do it at all
and so we are a bit detached from it
partly because
how do you do it how do you do something
like you do um you're
my favorite portrait artist i would say
on instagram your stuff is amazing um i
can see you have
a painting in the background is that
something you're working on now
yeah this portrait is a portrait
commission um
and i'm still working on it but it's
almost finished so i wanted to show it
and also i have something in my academic
years
that is part of my training to create
that sense of volume and
and with subtle whites so if you can
learn how to do solitude with whites
then with a flesh color which is a
little bit more you know
rich in color then i can manage that
to make it look 3d but okay well we'll
get to that you'll be able to
read that we'll get into all that yeah
um let's start off by could you give a
brief background of who you are and what
it is that you do for my audience
yes i was born in cuba and uh you know
the situation in cuba very poor so
always engage with my environment always
um
thinking of ways to use things as tools
or
opportunities that come up um helping my
parents do stuff finding food so it was
a very entertaining
childhood and hands-on and then when i
was 12
we but i always drew i always had
my parents put me in different sports
they kept me busy
but drawing was something that i always
went back to
and in the states actually is when i was
12
we immigrated from cuba to miami
and uh the new language was definitely a
barrier
i was in school pretty much lost and in
drawing class
was the only class that i could excel
and do what i communicate
and then there is what i learned how
drawing can even
guide me in my life because thanks to my
passion my teacher saw it
and she wanted to then she started
recommending me what better schools to
go to and
helping me and my parents to kind of
organize that so i'm
i learned at an early age that one of
the
organs of humans as a language was
of course a verbal language and also art
is a way to communicate definitely oh
that that's very interesting
um were you always able to draw was it
something that came naturally that was a
question
i asked i usually ask my audience if
they have questions for
the guest and one of the questions was
like i have no idea how to draw
i'm really bad at it how much of it is
talent
versus practice
well i believe that everybody can draw
in fact kids draw the thing is that we
are too judgmental about it and if we
don't draw with the expectations
of maybe a photography would uh do it or
something
mechanical if it doesn't represent the
real structures in nature
we get a shame but we have to think that
drawing is pretty much
symbolic it's something that comes as an
intuition like
kids they see the importance of their
family and you can see how
the head in even stick figures becomes
already something important for kids
like the head the mouth expression
and then kind of the body is pretty much
randomly
put there with sticks like all equal so
then you realize that it's not only
about seeing
that drawing is a lot about the symbol
and the meaning
of things instead of a visual optical
illusion you know how do you feel how do
you feel about abstract art versus
like you know i went to um moma
and this is when i was really ill so i
was kind of angry about everything
but i was looking at some of the
paintings that are like this huge canvas
that have two lines down it and i was
just irritated just like what i don't
understand this some people
absolutely love it and i was like that
doesn't you just drew a line in the
middle of a canvas like
what so um what
i've always i've always enjoyed i guess
portraits i find the most fascinating
because i think capturing a human is
insanely difficult even versus the
landscape
but landscapes are nice too i like
architectural drawings but
i have a difficult time with abstract
art so
what's what's your perspective on i
guess different forms of art and
well if you if you ever feel bad any
pain don't go to the moment
go to the metropolitan yeah that's a
that's a good idea i know that now yeah
what happened is that i what happened
with abstract art
is that it's almost like um it took
other art for inspiration
as an expression and then it became the
norm so in my school for instance the
reason i
dropped out of college after my fourth
year of studying art
was because i knew that it was a
never-ending story of just
theory and concept and i couldn't find
the connection with nature
so abstract art i think is just the
result
the beginning of abstraction at the turn
of the century
is uh it's an interesting thing because
that's when you know the industrial
world took
like science all these um aspects of our
lives
that used to work parallel kept doing
like for instance what i'm trying to say
is that as an artist
he's not concerned with you anymore he's
concerned
with him expressing his feelings so if
you see a rothko
with uh like just two main colors
emotionally applied that is
a dialogue only for the people that want
to be part of that dialogue it's not
really connecting
like you and me or my family
with art it kind of disassociated so art
became two things the visual arts in the
tv
and a conceptual art that comes from the
feeling of the
of the individual doing it and it's not
supposed to be
that much for anybody to kind of be
engaging
it's only if you want to play that game
while before
the art was part of the story of
humanity it's like science
you used to you used to build tools to
help you
have better lives express yourself then
when artists
did what they did all the people's
imagination grew
and they thought of new things and
that's how normally you went
but as soon as art started i mean
science started studying itself
and abandoned nature that's what
happened with art art became
also uh an engine to study itself so a
lot of all these things
grew parallel to each other and detached
everybody from it you know
yeah okay that's that's kind of how i
felt in moma
it was colder than um looking at
portraits for instance um but then there
are some that are like i don't mind
jackson paul
i think that's kind of interesting and
obviously picasso resonated with
you know everyone not everyone but like
a lot of people
um although i still find picasso a bit
disconcerting when i look at it too
although i suppose most people do
yeah but if you look at picasso
preferences we can judge it because of
his distorted but actually it's a very
particular way
for him to see form and to see that
distortion and to like
even if you try to do something like
picasso it's really hard to do
because he only him has that vision in
him uh relating
to that type of interpretation of things
that he sees
and pollock i see him more as uh as this
guy
that is expressing his frustration in
art
so art shouldn't be his art
from the individual is something that is
a language of expression it will come
automatically depending
on the circumstances of that person
uh before for instance before they say
the the church
run the commissions around the artist
but the artists didn't come up
either with their own ideas so it's not
just is that
fair to say oh artists couldn't express
themselves freely
because the idea of becoming a painter
was already a system over the individual
so only when we became more individual
in the sense
of after the french revolution or the
all this that made us
more aware of our individuality is that
we became
more individual to in our expressing
things for our own selves you know
there were a number of things i kind of
stopped doing when i got healthier
and drawing and writing i would love to
see any
you know send me a couple of images
whenever i feel like i could
take a second and go grab one then i'd
be showing a bunch of people i think
it's in my closet give me one sec
i haven't drawn anything since high
school so this was
2011. so this is not me but that's the
kind of like
it was like a model right sketches i've
got that one
i like those big shapes of shadows you
see how you're doing the shadow shape
separate from the light i like that
yeah i didn't have that much of a
problem with like
well with shading but i could never do
color
and then this is this is my skeleton
so that's like i don't want the
reflection there but you know what i
like about both
is that it's almost the same section of
the body one is fuller and the one is
the other one is the lace
what is the skeleton and the other one
is two people
so that's actually yeah i didn't notice
that this one is very full
but you see how you can have uh you
decided to do that for some reason and
that's very important
it's like carl jung would say uh okay
you have these dreams you're in
with anxiety and all these problems
paint it the moment you paint it
you connect to it you make it happen you
take action and then
that creates an image that is only yours
and that's why it's beautiful to see
that because now
i can see your at that time a little bit
of
psychology of looking things from a
deeper kind of way without even you
knowing you know you might be attracted
to that it's like you that's it you
like you aim and it's guiding you
yeah i had some i had some weird
drawings i had drawings of like
when i was really sick i i had this
repeated snake that i used to draw which
was the snake with no eyes and lots of
teeth
and and i don't normally like i usually
draw like i
said before draw things i can see and
just copy them onto a page
but there was this blind snake that i
was drawing it was really creepy
i'll try and find it before i put out
the episode i don't know if i can i may
have gotten rid of it but it was like
me and then there'd be these snakes in
the background and then i i really
stopped drawing as soon as i got
healthier stop drawing and writing um
which is a shame but i think i think i
was doing it for a therapeutic reason so
well now you're painting because though
the podcast
that you're doing i see it as a painting
you're bringing me
in my little painting something to see
and look into and in a positive way so i
believe you're a creator you're creating
it so i think it's just a transfer of
energy
and the more because in order for you to
paint that and evolve into a language
you have to go like that start
exaggerated skeletons
big pregnant women and then you keep
doing stuff like this
and in years then you narrow in and
become more precise with your expression
but it only happens in time like your
podcast is becoming like that and that
would happen
i mean even when i was drawing i i took
a van
uh with my wife and i lived six months
around the states and
and i felt like i was the t the drop the
van was the tip of the pencil
and i was drawing around america and
i was aware of every second at every
moment
so i was aware of the rendering of it
and just like when i draw so
i think it's uh we have a lot of
similarities to drawing in our lives
okay this is a bit of a more practical
questions for the artists listening but
how do you find clients how do you get
commissions
how do you make this into a business i
mean you're really good
so that helps but no no but i it's funny
enough that
you know that is a mystery there is a
bunch of strategies
i wouldn't recommend anything other than
developing the art within
and like i said before is funny enough
that when you do it
other people see it and they invite you
to either openings or to buy it or to do
something
so as soon as you start instead of
marketing there's a lot of things out
there how to be successful this and this
and that
and i think that's just after the fact
comes from observation of what happened
but if you if you were starting from the
battle
i believe that preparing yourself
fully so when you earn a commission you
can execute well
and then you do little things maybe to a
friend maybe do a cheap or maybe
show at a restaurant like whatever
opportunity comes your way
as a as a painter as a visual artist
take it and perform
the best you can and then from there
maybe you get more platforms open to
platforms open to you and then like that
yeah so develop your art and say yes to
opportunity
pretty much rather than following some
marketing plan that probably won't work
anyway
you're not gonna be able to fake it with
art like sometimes you can see people
pushing money into something
and you can see a bubble but it burst
it's not real
and sometimes even if we don't
understand a certain art
and it's up there uh and everybody
agrees and it is
it's worth something there might be
something i always consider
that i'm missing something about it if
it doesn't touch me rather than saying
oh that's a hoax
that's uh something that was fakely
created i believe that humans have to
have the capacity to judge when
something is really
useful or or real and how much is it so
the whole market what i believe uh and i
the best advice i could say maybe to
people
is to not draw things that are already
approved to be pretty like you were
brave you did a skull
someone pregnant nude like those things
you found
important at that time for some reason
and i think if if we look
out of the seduction in art and a lot of
the the pretty things to create pleasure
it stays light there is something that
was influenced
on you to create that but if you don't
do that you start from the bottom and
you propose what beauty is
because beauty is that when you find
that order in nature and you put it
together
um in a drawing or a painting and i and
i
yeah and i believe that's the best way
to approach it like just go different
don't prejudge it you know
yeah okay uh where can people find you
online i know that i
i know your instagram but tell people
where to find you online i have a
youtube channel that i talk a lot about
our subjects and it's cesar santos
caesar santos my name
uh on youtube and i also have a website
where i teach
um it's a scissor santos.com um
and that is also like i in my studio
filming myself talking about it what i
paint and i have different examples
there but that's that's
where it is yeah and that's
c-e-s-a-r-s-a-n-t-o-s
yes and that's your instagram as well
right yeah
okay perfect well thank you very much
for coming on i think people will find
this helpful
yeah it was nice talking to you yeah
finally i know we've been chatting on
instagram for a very long time so this
was fun
i know i look creepy and uh it's hard to
get to know someone like that with
flashing images of whatever they come up
with but
you don't come off as creepy you come
off as an artiste
thank you so much and thank you for
doing such a great inspirational
job with your family and everything oh
my god you're so
needed in this time so thank you not
only for talk to me but for doing what
you're doing
because uh it's not easy to go through
heart problems
uh that nature puts you in there you
know
so yeah freaking nature at it all the
time i know i know
you